الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث قالت
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت عشره
مسيره خلاله هجوم روسيه على جنوب شرقي
البلاد الليله الماضيه كما قالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها تصدت
لمحاولات تقدم روسيه في مقاطعه
في المقابل قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قوتها صدت 16 محاولات هجوم اوكرانيه في
محور
محمود عود على بدء اقليم دومباس في عين
العاصفه كل الاحداث الان وتطورات
الميدانيه تتركز هناك صحيح ان ثمه بعض
التطورات في ذابولوجيا او خيسون ولكن
عمليا يمكن القول بان العقده الاساسيه في
الدومباس هي ما فعل كل المواجهات خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه سواء بجناحي
الدومباس مقاطعه لوغانسك او مقاطعه دنيا
هنالك محاولات من الطرفين من القوات
الاوكرانيه للتقدم وتغيير المعادله
الميدانيه من خلال احداث ثغرات في عدد من
الجبهات في المقابل تمت دفع روسي ايضا
لمحاوله تغيير المعادله وفق المعطيات
الميدانيه والصادره عن القيادات الرسميه
العسكريه الاوكرانيه هنالك مواجهات امتدت
من محور ليمان وايضا وصولا الى باخمون
مرورا ومارينكا
تلك المناطق هنالك محاولات حديثه من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه للدفع بقواتها للسعي
الى اعاده السيطره على بعض المناطق التي
كانت قد فقدتها خلال هذه الحرب التي تستمر
منذ العام الماضي وبالتالي وفق المعطيات
الرسميه حتى الان
لمتغير جدي في هذه المنطقه ايضا هنالك
حديث عن مسيرات استهدفت عددا من المناطق
وتحديدا جنوب وجنوب شرق اوكرانيا تحدثت
القياده الاوكرانيه عن اسقاط سبعه عشر
مسيره هي بطبيعه الحال في بيانها لم تشهر
المناطق التي تم استهدافها لاشيمه بان
غالبا ما تساجف هذه المسيرات القواعد
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في عدد من المناطق
بالاضافه الى كل ذلك يمكن الحديث عن تطور
يرتبط بالسلاح الذي تسلمته اوكرانيا
وتحديدا الذخائر العنقوديه التي يجري الان
الحديث عن انها قد تؤدي الى متغير ما
مستوى خط الجبهه بين الطرفين على الاقل
هذا ما تعول عليه القياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه ولكن ثمه من يطرح اسئله
وتساؤلات حول هل فعلا قدره هذه القذائف
العنقوديه والذخائر على تغيير المعادله
ولكن بالعوده الى كل التطورات اليوم يمكن
القول بان الدومباس في قلب المعركه وهذا
ما اكدت عليه تصريحات الرسميه لهيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه التي تحدثت عن تقدم
على مستوى الشمال وجنوب ضخموت وايضا عن
صدها لكل محاولات التقدم التي قامت بها
القوات الاوكرانيه في دنيا فلنتابع الكلام
الصادر عن هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
يواصل الجيش الاوكراني وعملياته الهجوميه
في اتجاهات
وقد حققت قوتنا المسلحه نجاحات وتعمل على
تعزيز مواقعها وتواصل عمليات القصف
المدفعي والصاروخي للهدف المعاديه كما تشن
قوتنا المسلحه هج وما شمال وجنوب مدينه
بخموت حيث حققت نجاحات وتثبت قواعدها
القوات الروسيه هاجمت مناطق
كوبيانسكا ومارينكا وتمكنت قواتنا المسلحه
من صد كل الهجمات
ابقى معنا مازن ابراهيم نتحول الى كارمن
جوخدر من موسكو لمتابعه اخر التصريحات
الروسيه
نعم محمود الميداني يتقاطع ايضا مع
التصريحات السياسيه خاصه بعدما جرى في قمه
ليتوانيا اليوم نحن نشهد على مرور اربعين
يوما على بدء هذا الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
يمكن القول ان خطوط التماس ثابته ولم
تتغير ومشاهدناه في الايام الاربعين
الماضيه كان كرا وفرا كان محاولات للسيطره
في تلك المناطق الرماديه التي لا تخضع
لسيطره اي من الطرفين ولكن فيما تبقى من
الصيف واذا التعويل الاوكراني على الاسلحه
التي وصلت الى كييف والتي يمكن ان تصل بعد
الوعود في ليتوانيا حديث من قبل الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عن ان هذه الاسلحه
لن تغير في الميدان ولكنها ستساهم فقط في
اطاله الناد الصراع من بين هذه الاسلحه
محموده التي جرى الحديث كثيرا عنها هي
القنابل العنقوديه اليوم موقع ريدوفكا
العسكري الروسي القوات الاوكرانيه استخدمت
هذه الذخائر في مقاطعه زاكو ازاء هذا هذه
التصريحات والتطورات المرتبطه بالسلاح
تطورات ايضا ميدانيه داخل روسيا اليوم
الاراضي الروسيه تعرضت لعدد من الهجمات
الاوكرانيه نتحدث عن هرونش جنوب غرب روسيا
اسقطت فيها ثلاث مسيرات بريانسك وبيل غرود
ايضا تعرضت لقصف اوكراني ولكن التوصيف
الروسي اليوم الى ان الاخطر هو ما جرى في
كورسك محيط محطه كورسك النوويه تعرض
لاستهداف بمسيره لم يؤدي الامر الى اضرار
بالغه ولكن هذا الامر ندعو هذا الحدث ندد
به الكرملان ووزاره الخارجيه وحتى
الخارجيه ذهبت الى توصيف هذا الحادث بانه
ارهاب نووي من قبل الغرب تستخدمه اوكرانيا
هذه التطورات محمود داخل روسيا مرتبطه
بطبيعه الحال وتكثيف هذه اله الاوكرانيه
الناتج ومرده الى ما يجري في الميدان على
راس هذه المقاطعات التي تشهد قصفا وهجمات
مكثفه من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه وفق وزاره
الدفاع في الطليعه 16 هجمه في ال 24 ساعه
الماضيه في دنيا وحدها بالاضافه الى
المقاطعات الاخرى في خاركف قتال بين
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه هذا
المثلث بين خار كيف دانيت وايضا لوغان
ايضا مسرح لهذا القتال زكروجيا في قلب
الصراع دائما وخرسون ايضا تحاول القوات
الروسيه ابعاد القوات الاوكرانيه عن جسري
انطونوف وزاره الدفاع اليوم تحدثت عن
الواقع الميداني عن استهداف مستودعات
للاسلحه وعن كل هذه الهجمات لنستمع الى
ابرز ما قاله ايغور كونشنكوف المتحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
جنه القوات الاوكرانيه محاولات هجوم فاشله
في
محوريمان في محور دونيتسك صدت قواتنا 16
هجوما للعدو في يوم واحد وبلغت خسائره في
هذا المحور
280 عسكريا اوكرانيا وثلاثه مركبات قتاليه
مدرعه كما اعترضت انظمه الدفاع الجوي تسعه
صواريخ من طراز هايمرس واربع عشره مسيره
اوكرانيه في خاركيف ودونيتس كوزافوروجيا
وخيرسون
شكرا جزيلا لكارمه من موسكو وكذلك مازن
ابراهيم من سلوفيانس